let's jump into this first story man
it's the it's the last show of the year
so we're going to talk about Carrie Lake
and uh I I was watching this trial all
day I gotta pull up the story from Fox
News because this is just it's
absolutely insane Fox News publishes
this story Carrie Lakes opening Salvo in
election fraud case appears to fall
short it's not a fraud case Carrie Lakes
trial right now is about invalid ballots
Lakes fraud allegations didn't appear to
explain her 17 000 vote lost to Katie
Hobbs she did not make a fraud
allegation they explicitly said they are
not making a fraud allegation it's crazy
to me not so surprising when even Fox
News is not telling the story correctly
so I'll give you the gist of what we saw
yesterday and where we're at today so
yesterday what do we hear one witness
testified that he was given a sample of
certain ballots and he found that in all
of the samplings there were 19-inch
images printed on 20 inch paper which we
know from both the defense and the
plaintiff would the machines would
reject that we he then testified the
ballots were then duplicated but the
originals were not stored along with
them breaking chain of custody and
that's the one that's crazy to me like
is anybody talking about that like if
you fill out a ballot and they told you
to put it in box three and you did
because it didn't count they would
duplicate it and run the duplicate
through the machine and then they lost
the original so how do we compare these
two and know they're actually the same
that should have been brought up we then
heard from one witness that 298 000
ballots had no chain of custody this
one's simple the judge should have just
said to the defense can you produce the
chain of custody document in question
they didn't have it they didn't produce
it I don't understand how we're at this
point today we heard from the people's
pundit Richard Barris he said that exit
polling returns for election day were
substantially lower than anything he's
ever seen ever I think he said something
like 72 percent when he normally looks
for around 95 to 98 returns and he
believes this is because people did not
people were not able to vote so thus
they did not come back
now this was challenged but he basically
said due to the errors they talked to
voters voters said that there were long
lines in their tabulation machine
problems and because of that he believes
people did experience issues people
reported issues and thus a substantial
amount of Voters were disenfranchised
they argued against this today but I
think it's particularly compelling but
keep in mind it's not definitive proof
it's circumstantial evidence ultimately
what we end up getting in the closing
arguments
and this was really good for the defense
they said it your honor you instructed
in your uh in your uh ruling that the
plaintiff would have to prove
intentional misconduct with the intent
to to basically subvert the election or
flip it in another Direction and they
have not proven that
that's that's important because the
judge is going to be like you're right
you can't prove an individual acted
intentionally in an effort to hurt
Carrie Lake therefore even if the
ballots are invalid or otherwise doesn't
matter that makes no sense to me because
if I trip and fall and accidentally
subvert an election that election got
subverted so it would be no good you'd
have to do a new one it doesn't matter
what my intentions were but the but I I
guess as per the law the the judge ruled
if you can prove that someone
intentionally acted to alter the outcome
of the election then they would be that
that's what they that was the
stipulation for what they needed to win
and it appears the only evidence they
presented was that yes at I think it was
like six six locations they tested they
found the ballot tabulators were
misconfigured the only way the
misconfiguration could happen is if
someone intentionally altered the
printer settings it was not an accident
and then the defense contents okay and
even if someone intentionally did that
you can't prove the person who did did
it to hurt Carrie like therefore we win
oh that I mean that is a leap if you
intentionally do something
uh that subverts an election
what that doesn't matter if it was about
Carrie is not even it doesn't make sense
if they intentionally changed it to a
19-inch ballot then that was intent and
Blake what do you make of of this uh you
know court hearing what's your
assessment on what you're saying well I
think the standard that the judge is
requiring is even higher right it's
actually
Terry's team had to show intent plus a
different result they had to show the
intent and the result would have been
different but for all of these changes a
tangible really hard to prove we'll see
what the judge rules tomorrow right but
what's indisputable is that Kerry and
her legal team have shown they've just
put out in front of everybody all these
called them whether it's mistakes or
active malfeasance the election was
really messed up it was really messed up
like people went to go vote on Election
Day and the machines didn't work what
the printers did not work how does that
happen and and I think third world as
well one of the witnesses said 132
voting locations there were issues
yeah it's like 30 of the voting
locations yeah it's really great I think
and Abe hobby day the Attorney General
right his election was certified as a
loss by like 500 votes and I know he's
in litigation too and they're doing a
recount but 500 votes and everybody of
good conscience knows and we sued on
Election Day to try to get the polls to
stay open for a couple more hours that
was rejected had the polls stayed open
one more hour Abe would be going into
his recount probably up a few thousand
votes because those votes on Election
Day were breaking heavily for
Republicans so Abe's was super close and
I think that obviously swung it carries
at 17 000 I think she has a good claim
that like hey if the printers worked and
people could actually vote when they
showed up that she'd be the governor of
Arizona let's let's let's let's argue uh
for the sake of argument let's say the
voter tabulation problems and all that
didn't exist
a witness testified that 298 000 ballots
had no chain of custody
how do how can you verify where those
ballots come from and then you actually
I'm pretty sure the defense defense's
own witness uh I'm not sure if it was
Jared testified like well yeah we we
didn't track that but by law they have
to so okay hold on there a minute if
if I was a judge and someone came to me
and said the margin 17 000. and these
290 000 have no chain of custody I'd say
well okay that's against the law new
election end of story I bet the judge
won't do that because the law doesn't
say hey new election right and I think
we need to change the state law I think
the state legislature should say hey if
you can't prove chain of custody you
can't assume that's a fair election but
it appears that the burden of proof
right now is on the Kerry Lake team the
judge is going to say well hey okay
chain of custody that was broken that's
technically a violation of the law but
what's the remedy right you haven't
shown me that they injected new ballots
and that's probably impossible to prove
maybe it didn't happen right what what
happens to this state if the judge comes
out and says yeah you know it's against
the law to not have chain of custody but
uh too bad I mean what are the people I
have to imagine half of this state and
and and let alone how the elections
impact the rest of the country but I
mean if if I lived here and I was a
voter and I was told in the Press by the
judge and by everyone these these
ballots have a chain of custody so we
can't verify them but we're going to
count them anyway how could I have faith
in that system it'd be really hard to
and that's unfortunate right like
whether Republicans win or not like I
want everybody to know that their vote
counted I want everyone to know that we
have a first world election system and
the truth is that as soon as you
criticize our elections people call you
an election denier right well we have
better elections than some countries and
we have worse elections than almost
every Western democracy right and the
truth is somewhere in the middle and
apparently what we're learning in
Maricopa is you can botch an election
you can just botch it and if no one can
prove that you did it with the purpose
of putting your thumb on the scale and
that it actually mathematically changed
the result you can get away with it how
about this it was um Maricopa County
testified I believe it was like Maricopa
County correct me if I'm wrong please
double check all this I'm watching the
trial and there's a lot that SB Parts
through but they initially testified
that 19-inch ballots could not appear on
20-inch paper then when the plaintiff's
witness came up and said actually yeah
we have of it and they published images
of this they come back today and go oh
actually we knew about that problem it
affected three other elections and it's
like hold on and he's like now we're
doing a root cause analysis of that so
but you said the other day it couldn't
happen now you're saying oh yeah we knew
about that okay so you knew that was a
problem it's been a problem you didn't
fix it to me it's insane that what we're
basically hearing is the election was
improperly done in two ways the ballot
tabulators were improperly configured
they knew it was they knew it was
improperly configured they're trying to
figure out how and there was lost chain
of custody on these ballots and they
would just be like yeah well you know
the crazy thing to me is this is the
will of the people the utmost of the
utmost importance for our nation for
each state for each jurisdiction to know
that we are governed with the consent of
the people but that they would come out
and the judge would be like yeah these
these call into question the Integrity
of the election but we're gonna roll
with it anyway I mean I think people are
going to lose their minds if that ends
up being the ruling and I'll tell you
there's already a lot of appetite for
more election Integrity in Arizona right
it carries whole platform was I'm going
to go in and clean this up
whether you're Republican or Democrat
I'm going to bring more transparency to
the system right we're going to reform
all this stuff and now if we don't get
that opportunity
it's my heart breaks for people in
Arizona it's like why would anyone trust
it so Blake you ran for the Senate you
did not win
what's what's different about your
election how did it go you know what was
it well the margin is different you know
I think I was I lost by about 125 000
votes was the official difference
between Mark Kelly and me and uh you
know I think I drew a tougher opponent
and he's an astronaut and man he nuked
me with like 30 or 40 million dollars
right and and uh
you know we thought about suing and and
was this you know was this the right
thing to do and ultimately with all our
analysis like no it wasn't because as
messed up as this election Maricopa was
you can't make up 125 000 votes like I
don't think I won the election right now
I don't have to have enough Integrity to
say that I can't sell false hope to my
people like I said Abe hamide 500 votes
this stuff in Maricopa County absolutely
swung 500 votes now Carrie has the
interesting in between right 17 000 and
they get that's that's what her trial
was and she's trying to prove that but
for this incompetence called
incompetence at best malfeasance at
worst but for this incompetence I would
have won 17 000 votes we'll see let's
let's let's uh hammer that one down
let's say that Kerry Lake's initial
argument was I understand that it was
one big misunderstanding by everybody
nobody intended to do this improperly
but clearly we can see that the vote
margin could be different if not for all
these tabulators being wrong the law
could not remedy that that's right the
law requires intent it requires intent
and it's not could be different it was
different it would have been different
and that's that's a really hard bar it's
a really hard bar oh that's that's
insane that that's not real governance
real governance is saying okay what do
we know and let's apply remedy on the
facts they're saying regardless of the
facts there's a high standard that must
be met meaning they could the system in
place right now would actually put a
person in power who didn't win I'm
saying hypothetically
just because the standard is too high to
to to to to change it
I think it's insane because if I were to
do something like destroy someone's
property but I didn't do it to hurt them
that wasn't my intention my intention
was just like oh I didn't have intention
I just actually destroyed your house but
I didn't intend to hurt you no crime
yeah apparently when it comes to the you
apply that's of the political landscape
it's not a crime that makes no sense I
mean intention is irrelevant when you're
in talking about someone disrupting and
destroying things well like if you feel
you're right somewhat somewhat if
somebody dies and it's no intense
manslaughter it's like if you're
reckless or whatever if you intend to do
it now it's murder but it's still a
crime it is still a crime so potentially
you could be driving in your car and you
could hit somebody and it could be
totally accidental and you don't go to
jail for it so the difference here is
that person still lost their life we
still like knowledge they lost your
their life you maybe still held uh
liable civilly we're talking about an
end process where one person will be the
executive in government in government
meaning there is a very simple remedy if
we can see that something lacks
Integrity in the election we hold a new
election because we're trying to get the
will of the people done right thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time